when you go fish in a part of the pond
that nobody else is fishing because
everyone else thinks the water is too
deep and it's too scary over there the
rewards are like disproportionate even
to the effort in the work that goes on
[Music]
all right what's up
what up dude how are you doing um who
did you have as a guest on the last
episode when i i was doing my own
episode and then you tweeted out you
wanted to guess who came on
two different people the first was our
own ben and so ben and i did an episode
where we talked about like
uh thing people in history and if
there's any commonalities between a
bunch of them and then noah kagan my
friend noah from appsumo i asked him if
he would come on and he said yeah so i
just recorded two that day
cool did they turn out kid or you know i
mean we'll see noah noah was good uh ben
and i was good as well i just hope that
i don't know if that top the topic is
gonna be a winner so we'll see noah is
amazing do you know about appsumo
uh i know like loosely about appsumo so
here's what they tell you what i know
you tell me what i don't know so
what i know is that appsumo is basically
it's a website where you can go to
get like kind of software deals i would
say um
they kind of like they go find cool
software they make a deal they say hey
we'll get you in front of like whatever
50 million people but you got to offer a
deal to our audience like sort of
groupon style or woot style
and apparently he's doing extremely well
he's been doing it for a long ass time
10 plus years i think it does over 100
million in revenue so that's what i know
about it
almost all right so appsumo started as
basically noah he emailed the founder of
imager uh and basically said hey you
guys charge ten dollars a month if i
give you a bunch of new customers at six
dollars a month can i get a little cut
of the pie right and that's how we
started he made 10 grand doing that by
emailing a bunch of friends eventually
it kind of still is this way but they're
gonna they're becoming more of a
marketplace and a website but for like
the last 10 years it's basically an
email list and i think there's only 300
000 people on that email list and they
email out a few deals a week where they
find uh companies that say hey give us a
discount and give us a cut of the
revenue right and
it was doing okay for years it just some
years it didn't do better than the year
before sometimes it did a lot better and
i think it only did okay for a few years
now after close to 10 years he their
goal this year was 100 million in
revenue they're going to miss it by a
little bit but he said they're going to
get north of 80 million in revenue now
he didn't say it on the podcast if i
just if you just google it it appears of
that 80 million in revenue they pay out
30 to their partners and they get around
60 or 70 of the of the actual revenue
and he owns most of the company has
never taken any outside money and they
have like 150 employees at this point
wow uh i didn't realize
some of those things and
uh okay so 300 000 people on the list so
do you know if they send out an email
about some product
uh have they ever done it for the hustle
by the way did they ever like did you
promote the hustle in there somehow or
no because it's already a free email
i i know i don't well no i don't think
we've done it in a traditional way it's
maybe true i think we've done trends but
we've not done it in a major way so you
can um sometimes they'll only send it to
part of the list and i think that we've
done like a part list but uh some of
their partners they'll make
over a million dollars in the in one day
well i guess my question is how many
people take them up on their offer so
how many do they need for this this
business to kind of work so is it
because i think it seems like maybe
bigger than it is i wouldn't be
surprised if it's like yeah a thousand
people click the thing and a thousand
people is enough
for this business to work when a
thousand people take the offer is it a
thousand or more like ten thousand uh i
would think that it's in the single
digit thousands if i had to guess that's
how many buy because the products are
like
a year or something like that so you
don't actually need that many people to
buy in order to make 500 000 to a
million of dollars and you're saying
they're sending emails constantly and
now they have a website that people are
doing stuff now here's where it gets
interesting i asked him
how much could you sell this business
for right now he was like
the huge range is 300 million to a
billion i think that's what he said
right
pretty crazy right it's it's it it's
like noah good job good job noah and
like a lot of things like the hustle
included like people are like and i say
it as well well it's just an email list
it's really simple and yeah that's true
it is just an email but there's
definitely a machine behind it and
appsumo is like inherently quite simple
um they just holler at companies they
say give us a discount and give us a cut
of the pie and then they just email that
out to people
and it's so simple and it just creates
so much value
there's a ryan hoover did this a while
back he created a list of big companies
that started off as quote unquote just
email list so he created product time
product started off as an email list
uh production got acquired by angellist
which is like a
three billion-ish dollar company or more
angelus started as just an email list
just a list of angels that he was doing
craigslist started off as an email list
and so there was a whole bunch of
products that started off as just an
email list some became more than that
some stayed an email list yeah
groupon started out groupon is basically
was an email list for a long time right
and so you know don't underestimate do
not underestimate email uh that's not
tattooed on sam's back uh do not
underestimate email let's talk about a
couple things i have a i have another
business id i have another business i
want to highlight that's a uh one of
these like
that's so simple are you joking that's
the business but first before we do that
one
we gotta talk about this squid games
thing that happened the beast games by
mr beast um did you watch it when it
happened or have you watched it after
the fact i heard basically casey neistat
who i follow on twitter was talking
about saying mr beast uh what he's doing
with the squid games thing is one of the
most epic things i've ever seen on
youtube and casey neistat is one of the
pioneers of youtube and him saying that
meant a lot
yeah exactly that's you know denzel
saying wow the great acting in this
movie so all right so um
for those who didn't see it all right so
squid games was this ultra popular i
think it is the most popular show ever
on netflix um
those watch show
and it's this kind of like crazy
uh korean
death game show type of idea where you
know a bunch of people enter this game
and they're trying to win the big prize
and then they get killed they're losing
is like you die basically that's like
the short version of it i actually
didn't watch squid game so maybe i got
something wrong there but
i did watch the mr beast version of it
so what did mr beast do he basically
decided i'm gonna recreate squid games
but i'm not obviously people aren't
gonna die but he did it even better so
he invited 456 people to this arena that
was built for this
and the prize was the number one the
winner of the games was gonna win 456
thousand dollars runner-up 10k and
everybody who
who went got two thousand dollars each
and in total the production plus the
prize money so i think he did about
a billion and a half dollars of prizes
and two million to build and produce it
three and a half million dollars is what
he spent on this content on this 25
minute video so let's talk about what
happened so first uh players showed up
they're wearing the same outfits as in
squid games it's like kind of green
windbreaker jumpsuit type thing
and they all have a number so player one
player 2 player 3 all the way up to
player 456
and inside their shirt they have this
like pack
and the pack is like
exploding paint so if you let's say one
of the games is called red light green
light the old like game we used to play
as a kid where if you say green light
you start moving red light means you got
to stop if you keep going after they say
red light you're out and so
they here's a green light then you see a
red light and if somebody flinched after
that their little pack inside their
shirt would explode and red paint would
come out as if they got shot like you
know like the real squid games and then
they would be out and then hey you got
to go to the next
you didn't make it to the next game
and so in the end uh you know player
whatever player 27 ended up winning 456
thousand dollars so here's i think this
is amazing and this ties into some stuff
we've been talking about so
just some numbers the video got about
130 million views in seven days which is
crazy i think i i believe ben you can
fact check me on this i believe 130
million views is more than what the
actual squid games got on netflix now
netflix is a paid service and whatever
but like and people watched uh like
multiple episodes yeah 12 hours of
footage it's yes it's still amazing the
fact that it's comparable the fact that
somebody just watched the show was like
oh yeah we'll do like a backyard version
of that and got 130 million people to
watch is insane so uh he spent three and
a half million on it just to kind of put
this in perspective
um
that's basically half the cost of a 30
second super bowl commercial
wow
really did you have a sponsor
it was fully paid i believe fully paid
for by brawl stars the the big the super
popular mobile game so if you look in
the arena where it was where it was
hosted it's a giant brawl stars arena
they have a huge logo that was in every
shot
and so for brawl stars this such a smart
move they basically paid half the cost
of a super bowl ad
got more viewership than a super blog
because you get 130 million people the
video is like 20 minutes long 27 minutes
long
versus a 30 second clip and um this is
an epic thing that's going to get shared
and then they could take this content
repurpose it for ads or anything else
they wanted to do after the fact if if
they wanted to so really smart you know
for brawl stars three million dollars is
probably their daily uh what is a one
day of ad spend on facebook or something
stars is owned by supercell and
supercell's like the the biggest game um
yeah and so if i i don't know if this is
how it would have worked if i'm mr beast
i think he could have so he would have
gotten supercell to pay for the whole
thing so three and a half million
dollars i bet he also would have gotten
another like five hundred thousand
dollars just like there's a vague on top
of yeah just like just for that and then
they would have probably i would have
said to them also i'm gonna keep youtube
ads on this right and mr b i get all of
it and so if mr beast is getting uh 130
million views in the first seven days
and if you do maybe four dollars per cpm
that's around half a million dollars
that he got in the first week plus i
believe his deal is going to be a lot
better than 4 cpm uh because he's the
number he's like you know one of the
faces of youtube these guys have custom
negotiated deals that i would bet a lot
of money is better than the standard
kind of four to five dollars what do you
think it is i bet he's getting closer to
10 cpm so if it's 10 that's 1.3 million
yeah and just in a week in a week plus
according to our notes it looks like he
got 10 000 new subscribers
sorry i'm sorry oh my god 10 million new
subscribers in the first week and a
normal week is 400 000 subscribers so he
is 20xed his subscriber growth so so
what does this do
he's continues to be the content leader
he gets 10 million new subscribers and
those people are gonna get notified for
his next video he makes a million
dollars on ads he gets the whole thing
paid for by a sponsor
and this is a great example of something
we've talked about before we talked
about this with elon when elon does epic
stuff like i'm gonna go to mars we
talked about it with i forgot the guy's
name mark lazary or whoever it was
that's building that epic train
train system uh in america uh i i ranted
about disney uh disneyland last week
because again when you shoot for these
epic projects things that get people
inspired and excited
it's it seems like it's harder to pull
off but in many ways it's easier to pull
off because you'll get talent to pour in
because they want to be a part of
something bold you'll get sponsors to
pour in because they want to bet on this
this epic thing that's going to happen
they know that it's going to get a lot
of visibility and so and you get your
own motivation to get out of bed every
day because you're working on something
that's so so grand that you know you're
more motivated everybody does their best
work and people tune in to watch which
is like so ben just looked it up 140
million 142 million people watched squid
games on netflix 132 million watched uh
beast games on youtube so about the same
one to one so you get
disproportionate prizes when you go fish
in a part of the pond that nobody else
is fishing because everyone else thinks
the water is too deep and it's too scary
over there the rewards are like
disproportionate even to the effort and
the work that goes in i had a friend it
could have been noah in fact you know
noah who we talked about he was the
number 20 or something employee at
facebook and he got fired nine months
into his uh employ working there and so
he didn't get any of his equity but i
have a friend who spoke to mark
zuckerberg and he said to mark you know
why don't you just sell the company for
a billion or why are you raising all
this money like things are growing he's
like look
it's good i only have 24 hours in a day
and i'm only going to work the same
amount of time in the day whether it's
big or small so i might as well make it
as big as i possibly can because that's
what interests me and it's just as hard
it's equally hard to go big as it is
somewhat like mild success and that's a
perfect example of what mr beast has
done is it's actually of equal work you
know same amount of time in the day but
when you see someone building someone
something so epic it's exciting so many
people who don't give a [__] about mr
beast of which i am one of them i know
about this and i cared about it small
ambition and large ambition take the
same amount of effort if you want to win
if you want them to work and uh and
that's exactly right and so i think this
was brilliant i think this is another
example of mr beast being one step ahead
of the curve you're gonna see a lot more
people try to clone this so the next
thing that comes out you're gonna see
four youtubers who are the wannabe mr
beast try to jump on it and recreate
this and by the way this wasn't the
first thing he did like this like
obviously he's been doing stunts but he
even did like a i'm gonna recreate
fortnite they like went to an island it
was 100 people playing paintball and it
was like a game of fortnight and he made
a video on that and i think it did well
but it wasn't this it wasn't this level
but it's those reps
that you you know you put in that give
you the a confidence and b shots on goal
until you get something to work like
this and i also was watching a clip of
mr beast yesterday
just coincidentally and somebody said
are you you know you've talked about you
want to be a billionaire you want to be
the you know
the quote unquote the first billionaire
creator although there have been other
creators that are worth a billion
dollars so
you want to be a billionaire and they're
like are you there are you there already
he goes no no no i'm not there yet and
he goes um he goes i'm probably the cash
wise i'm probably the poorest person in
this room and they're like no no way he
goes yeah because whatever i have is
like paper it's not like it's not liquid
and any cash i get i just reinvest the
next and reinvest my videos he goes if
we make three million dollars this month
i'll put three million dollars into the
next video we have razor thin margins um
he goes i just reinvest the whole thing
into content i think on average he said
he he said he was spending something
like two or three million dollars a
month on his content i would have bet
which is wild i would have guessed that
he uh made around two and a half three
million dollars a month in revenue i
would have guessed around 30 million in
revenue off his operation and so that
makes total sense in fact we talked to a
couple people i believe he has mr peace
has around 30 to 40 full-time people
working for him and i actually recently
read about like what i was like what is
it like to work with him and a lot of
people complained they said um
they said working with him is horrible
he's horrible to work with and i was
like well you know what's going on why
and they go he's a perfectionist i was
like oh okay so it's actually not that
bad
they would say why isn't this good
enough why is this so bad and he would
analyze every single frame and frankly
that made me even love him but there's
something interesting about this which
is i actually think
being him is exhausting because you have
to go up every single time and so let me
give you an example of two youtubers
that are incredibly interesting to me
graham stefan and meet kevin do you know
who those guys are i know graham stefan
i don't know me kevin all right meet
kevin i think is even more famous and he
has 2.5 or 3 million subscribers he
recently did a video and it was called
here's my entire 50 million dollar
portfolio at age 29. so i and i noticed
that he had done one of these i'm
clicking okay okay double click full
screen headphones on
and i noticed that he did another one of
these like nine months ago or 13 months
ago something like around a year ago and
his net worth then was only 25 and i was
like what is going on this guy is nuts
and so he's basically this guy meet
kevin i don't know his full name he um
makes like three to four videos a day
and he is talking about like which
stocks he's buying uh which um
types of houses he's buying for
investment properties and he shows his
entire portfolio and at the end he goes
now here's proof and he logs in to all
of his accounts and you can see all of
that screen share yes which is amazing
for many reasons one
he's only 29 and he's a youtuber with 50
million dollars
how is he how did he get that money so
he's just off of his youtube or he has
some other business that he
started with at age 19 i believe he
started as just a real estate agent so
just a normal guy okay and he made a
little bit of money like a hundred grand
a year took that hundred grand a year
and bought some properties and then
started a youtube channel in 2010 or
2011 and he just started documenting
about his real estate investing slowly
that started making additional income
using that income he bought even more
properties eventually he had like a
course and things like that where he was
making like one or two million dollars a
year so a significant amount of sum or a
significant sum
then he took that money and he started
investing it and started talking about
what he was investing and you could see
this entire growth over the last five
years of his portfolio and how it's
grown of course it helps that a he's got
now a significant stream of like 4
million a year i would imagine and we're
having the best bull market of all time
and so
it kind of works but that's how he's
done it and interestingly this guy kevin
uh when gavin newsom was being recalled
kevin ran for office and there's this
republican name larry elder who got
second behind gavin newsom kevin was
third with something like hundreds of
thousands of votes and so it's this
kid's amazing and so that's surprising i
feel like a youtuber who's got a big
following should crush any politician he
doesn't have that big of following he
only has 2.5 or 3 million it's not
significant and it has to be a
california above 18 voter so it's not
like it's not significant but my point
being with a lot of these youtubers is
this video was nutty and graham stefan
did the exact same thing he goes here's
my prediction
mr beast or a mr beast type person will
run for president and will surprise
people with the type of following they
get because oh absolutely whether you
want to be president or not you could
you know i think the original trump
playbook was i'm gonna just throw my hat
in the ring i'm gonna get tons of
attention and press i'm gonna build my
brand off the
the massive amount of attention that
goes into elections and i'll be the the
kind of curveball story that everybody
wants to cover everybody's got an
opinion on
like kanye kanye did it or whatever he
threw his name in you're gonna see the
wild wild west of people trying to put
their name in the hat for running for
office or running for these kind of like
positions that will sound
you know how could a how could a 21 year
old youtuber be doing this and they're
going to get a little momentum and then
that's going to create a press cycle
that's going to create more momentum i
don't think they'll actually win i don't
think they even want to win but it would
just be a smart move for the dog
dog-eat-dog world of youtube trying to
get views yeah
and but here's back to the original
point of getting views
what is exhausting life that you have to
go and and i'm thankful that mr beast
does what he does i'm thankful that this
kevin guy and graham are crazy enough to
log in and show me their that is so cool
they are [__] the success that is
nuts i had this exact thought the other
day we um i forgot who i was talking to
but i talked to somebody and it was like
oh yeah that's a great youtube i've had
like five ideas about like oh yeah if we
did that as a youtube video it would get
clicks right like one was
um i was gonna show how you can make ten
thousand dollars being a santa like a
santa claus for christmas and i was like
oh this is easy i'll buy the suit i'll
show the economics of that i'll go do
the thing that'll make for a funny
thumbnail and it'll make for this little
story that's semi-viral another one is
going and buying
buying fancy [__] and like actually like
justin khan did a video where he toured
a 50 million dollar home it was amazing
and it's a you know just it's
interesting content right it's like a
super it's junk food that people in our
niche we just like to consume that stuff
like oh yeah what is it like you know um
how do you do it how much money do you
make how do you invest it and there's
all these videos that you can make
around this
and every time i think of one i think
that would work i think to myself
i do not want to get on that treadmill i
just don't want to get on the treadmill
because i know
it's like
uh the difference between sort of like
uh knowledge and wisdom it's like i know
this would work but i'm also wise enough
to know that that is not a path i want
to double down on i do not want to
double down on the treadmill path
because i don't feel that way about this
podcast for example this podcast feels
ongoing it's a it's a breeze dude we
show up i just shoot the [__] with my
friend for an hour um people seem to
like it it's so like it's two hours of
my week that i like i'm on the i'm on
camera i'm on on i'm being recorded and
i don't have to like and also because
it's a podcast i'm not like
worried about how i look and the angle
and the this and that like maybe i
should a little more but i just don't
like the way that you do when you're
recording youtube videos and you have to
edit everything and clip it and like do
all these cuts podcasting is podcasting
has that risk reward ratio or that like
effort reward ratio that works for me
and this like youtube treadmill i think
has a much bigger prize
but
i don't want to win that way there's
other ways to win and that treadmill is
exhausting it's exhausting and there's
exhausting there's a reason why you
don't see casey neistat anymore i've
watched a couple of recent interviews
with him and he said now i don't do
anything he goes for those three years
that are recording daily vlogs
everything in my life everything in my
day if someone invited me to dinner i
had to message them and say i can't
unless someone interesting is coming or
you want to go somewhere intriguing
because it has to be content and i lost
a lot of friends me my wife almost
divorced and it was exhausting and now
he's 37 years old he's financially
successful and he goes
i'm not doing it anymore i have to take
a break and so i think it's cool to
dabble with it but i am wary of the
treadmill now you did a video so kind of
on the other side of the coin you've
been putting out your fitness content
which i think is probably just fun for
you and motivating it's fun and then you
did a video that i loved which was you
put a video up on i think your own just
your personal youtube channel of this
real estate project you're doing so i
wanted to ask you about this here's what
for those who didn't watch it here's
here's the the summary of the video
uh you bought a piece of land right next
to your house i think like adjacent to
or like literally
your neighbor you brought the neighbor
lot next to your house
and it's got this like really run-down
shack on it like it's a
large piece of grass with a really
shitty shack that somebody was living in
and it's 20 years it looks brutal like
this is like you know
i wouldn't wish this on an enemy uh
these conditions so it would look like
just like from this run-down shack and
you're like cool like here's the thing i
bought and you you broke down the
economics you're like you know i brought
this so how much did you buy for exactly
650 000
650 000 she bought the whole thing and
you bought it leveraged or you bought it
all cash
cash okay you bought it all cash why
didn't you borrow
because i wanted to purchase before they
put it on market so basically the
background buy now it was a 90 year old
couple that who owned it and they rented
it to a guy and i the day i moved into
this house i used a little bit of
research and i found who they were and i
said hey you know just so you know my
name's sam i'm i live now next year
property if anything ever happens you
want to sell this please contact me and
so the man died on a monday the wife
called me on a wednesday and said would
you like to buy it and i bought it on a
thursday
amazing okay i love that and you're like
this is going to be my first kind of
like you don't know [__] about real
estate you don't [__] about building any
like a home um and so you're like this
is gonna be fun it's gonna be a hands-on
project i'm gonna kind of document it as
i go and then you had this spreadsheet
which basically said all right look
i bought it for 650k and um and then you
know in this in this area there's a sort
of like a price per square foot that you
can get and here's the range and then i
talked you got bids from some
contractors and you were like you know i
can uh
you know on the low end it seems like
you could build it for this much and
then if i'm conservative and it might be
more expensive than we think it might
cost this much so i might have to put a
million dollars in to build the actual
structure in the home modern ground up
and uh so you know i might be in for 1.6
million but based on the the price per
square foot in this area i should be
able to sell this for two it should be
worth two or two point five like when
i'm done with this thing i'd like the
margin of safety was really strong it
seemed like just like a an absolute
no-brainer of a deal assuming this is
how you want to spend your time right
like the time is almost more expensive
or the risk here more so than
the buy is great you made your money on
the buy as they say in real estate
rather than trying to make your money on
the sale yes but it's not taking nearly
as much time and i'll tell you why so
what i did was before i even bought the
piece of property i found things in the
area that sold for my ideal price per
square foot right i went on zillow and
redfin i found the architect and then i
called them and then i also called the
builder and i go hey guys how much would
it cost to build this exact same home
right now right and they told me and i
go great um and how do you do that
yeah and i bought this flop a lot and i
call them again i go hey um you know
that house that just sold for a thousand
dollars a square foot do that again over
here for me please
you're not trying to innovate and add
the sandpark touches of like uh a you
know a 3 000 square foot gym and like a
thousand square foot house like you're
doing a normal house build out it's a
normal house build-out but i said make
it a two-car garage because i may if i
decide to live there i'll build the gym
there and that's basically it yeah okay
i just said i took i took a house that
was crushing it that i just sold for a
lot of money and i said and i hired the
same people and i said do it again by
the way so i'm not i'm not spending any
time on it i spend no time on it just
the fact that it's next door also is
surprisingly gonna be like a 50
savings in the time and headache that's
involved with this because
uh like my family did this we've we uh
we had a house in san francisco and then
we bought a house two doors down
and just the fact that it was two doors
down had like all these extra benefits
which was like it was super easy to go
see it was super easy to like manage any
construction that was going on it's they
like share a fridge in the like garage
it's like oh yeah just use the extra
fridge across the street uh my sister
runs a business out of one of them and
she's able to manage it from like
without having to get in her car and
commute somewhere and just
just it being like within eyesight and
and like a two-minute walk away is
so important and like if anyone's gonna
do a project like this
do not underestimate that i've now seen
it a couple times and i feel this way
this is my rule with friends and family
also which is
you want to live so close to your best
friends or family that you could go
unplanned to their house like you don't
need to pack a bag and think about okay
well then how like what you know when
should we go should we beat the traffic
and then yeah we're gonna have to head
back for the night it's like i should be
able to pop over and pop back unplanned
because it's so convenient and like the
difference between 15 minutes away
and four minutes away is gonna
fundamentally change the way like the
amount of times you you see that person
or do that thing so why did you bring up
that youtube video by the way because i
thought it was awesome oh thanks and i
just wanted to hear more about the like
and the like the actual real estate side
of the side i think that the the the
numbers are the way they're going to
work out and not a lot of people believe
me but i think it's gonna happen this
way
i'm gonna make half a million dollars in
profit or more from it i think there's a
world where i make closer to a million
than half a million there's i'm gonna
sell it or rent it out
there's a i have a few options i can
live in it and sell my home
yep but the way that all this math is
gonna work it's gonna be what both this
house and that house i'll have made
around a million dollars in profit in
like 18 months
right um because
things just worked out and so i'll make
more from this real estate project than
i will my entire
hustle salary combined ever
and it only in this project for example
but you're gonna have to invest right
that's the that's the kicker here so
like you you couldn't have done this
back then because you didn't have a
spare 1.6 million dollars to go like
invest in buying the lot plus building
the home out or if i did do it it was
like all of my money right exactly
so you know you would have to go like
completely all in on it can i tell you
what else we got can i tell you about
let me tell you about a company that
interests me
okay so i was talking to someone
recently and i can't say who it is but
they had a google chrome extension that
made something like 25 million dollars
in revenue with only two guys
two people
it's amazing so i got curious extension
did or no no i yeah um roughly
uh helping people on amazon sell stuff
okay cool so
like kind of like a what's that thing
called jungle scout something in that
world yeah um and so basically uh i
started i i got kind of curious so
there's two extensions that caught my
caught my attention the first and
they're basically the same thing with
almost exactly the same name the first
is this thing called ad block i think
that's the one i use the second one is
called ad bot ad block plus so that's
why it's a little confusing and so
adblock was created by one guy in
georgia named michael gundlach and he uh
he
just kind of built this thing in 2009
and he's been the only employee the
whole time and i went to his personal
website to learn about him and he only
has 55 followers on uh twitter his
website is called sorryrobot.com that's
his personal website and he has like
python projects a unity game that he
built called asteroids and even has an
mp3 of him singing a christmas song at
church during christmas time
this is like by the way his linkedin
his job description is just a guy
uh he is in duluth georgia and it says i
am not available for work please do not
contact me about job opportunities i
created adblock the most popular chrome
extension for google chrome extension
and for safari with around 20 million
users it's neat
before that i did some other neat things
and he was the only employee and then i
did some research on his competitor
called adblock plus now this company
they have a few few more employees i
think they've got 20 or 30 people and
because they're based in europe when
you're a european company oftentimes at
least in england and i know it's a lot
of the k uh a lot of cases in different
european countries if you make over 20
million dollars in revenue you basically
have to file a report that reveals your
revenue and profit and so i went and
looked at this company called io it's
called io they own ad blocker plus in
2017 they did 44 million dollars in
revenue and 26 million dollars in profit
which is astounding and they had at
least 100 million users
however if you look in the group the the
chrome plug-in store uh adblock plus has
around 150 000 reviews and it says
they've got over 10 million users if you
look at ad block which is the one
founded by this one guy they've got
something like 300 000 reviews
and uh
also it says 10 million users and so
there's potential that this one guy
had a business making all of this money
tens of millions of dollars a year very
likely tens of millions of dollars a
year in profit
just off a chrome extension is that
amazing this is amazing i'm i'm still on
this guy michael gunlock's uh
website sorry robot.com
resume
um pdf and
i i think you said this but i was
reading while you were talking so he was
an engineer at google working on google
ads and google adsense did you already
say that part no and he worked on google
and basically he goes nah [__] that i
hate these ads
so his job was he goes at google i kept
the global at google ads and adsense
networks alive and kicking um in my
spare time i built this other thing and
i built this other thing uh you know
like because google has that 20 times
like i built this javascript framework
blah blah so basically he goes from
working at google and google adwords and
ad sets to creating adblock
and makes 20 billion
makes more than that uh off 20 million
users who who love this thing and what
year did you work at google i believe
like oh five 2005 yeah so which is like
right after the ipo basically yeah so he
probably made 30 million dollars at
google like collectively it's pr that's
what it's worth now
if you held it so it made tens of
millions of dollars off of that and then
reportedly now the thing about this guy
is everything's very quiet about this
guy he's hard to find everything's
impossible however i think in 2015 an
anonymous buyer bought adblock
interesting there's a world where it
could have been sold for like two or
three hundred million dollars i mean
there's a world where that exists uh
maybe it was lower but it was it's a
it's a huge problem like he stopped he
he stopped working on ad block or you
know it sold probably 2015 which is kind
of scary because these chrome extensions
are a giant security hole for people
because chrome extensions can like read
and write all the data on your
as you browse the web so that's all
every email you're writing the text is
can be picked up by these chrome
extensions and even if they start off
safe because you know just a guy from
duluth georgia built it and he's an
engineer who has the right intentions
somebody who buys it with the wrong
intentions can really like
do some dirty stuff yeah you know with
the data and even modifying it and
things like that so you got to be
careful with chrome extensions i try to
install the minimum amount of chrome
extensions as possible yeah they are
pretty scary and um yeah they're nuts
and the but it's a
wild business i think that what here's
here so i love these extension style
businesses there's a few platforms that
i think are quite interesting the first
google chrome still makes a ton of sense
the second
um shopify still makes a ton of sense
our friend andrew has a business where
all he does is buy
buys uh shopify plugins and it's market
cap it's a publicly traded company it's
like in the 600 million dollar range
it's on the canadian stock exchange but
the third thing which you probably have
not thought of and the fourth thing you
definitely haven't thought of salesforce
plug-ins and then finally zoho plug-ins
incredibly interesting so we used to
hire this engineer uh
at the hustle and he would he was in
another country and we would pay him 20
bucks an hour to just build little apps
for us for our sales team
and uh
i think zoho i would imagine is which is
like a salesforce competitor but a
little jankier has an equal amount of
users as salesforce i think you could
build a really great business just doing
salesforce plug-ins right yeah and we're
rolling them up um so i i don't know if
i'm allowed to talk about this but i'll
say it in a vague way
uh
met a guy i heard about a guy that was
rolling up
games inside of a big gaming platform so
there's like a very popular game and
there's games within that or little like
modules people create and they monetize
and this person was rolling them up and
they're like dude does that mean like
these are created by like i don't play
games like you know okay so for example
there are big gaming platforms like
fortnight and minecraft and roblox and
like all these different games that
exist and inside the game you can create
little experiences and you can monetize
them um kind of like people who create
like different colored guns for call of
duty
yeah although i don't know if i don't
know if you could do people create those
i thought the game created those but
like yeah there's there used to be mods
and you know mods of different games and
maps and things like that that you can
create that's always been kind of like a
part of it but some of these games now
are so big and they actually like
formalize their little creator economy
inside the game
and
the person i knew was rolling them up
and they're like
these are
selling for nothing because they're like
it's just like a kid who made this it
sells for like less than you know like
1x revenue or something like that like
it's like crazy like compared to going
and buying that same cash flowing asset
on whether it's fba or shopify or
something else now everything has a
different profile of like maybe this
game is a fad maybe people will stop
using this maybe you know the game will
change the rules and you're screwed all
of a sudden so yeah there's some risk
but uh
i love these game plans of go to these
niche platforms we've talked about etsy
we've talked about poshmark um fba we've
now talked about zoho and salesforce and
slack and like all these different
platforms
there are little apps that just make
fifty thousand dollars a hundred
thousand dollars fifty thousand dollars
a month and
you can go and you can buy these out and
you can roll them up and you can have a
company that does 10 to 20 million
dollars of revenue profitably and you
could buy your way there uh without even
having to invent anything all you got to
do is go get cheap cheap debt
buy this thing and profit um and it's
really like that simple but there's one
major thing which is if call of duty or
fortnight or whatever it is they go
hey we're gonna go in a different
direction yeah exactly
and that's why you got like that's the
same thing with fba right and
all these like thoracio and all these
roll-ups
fba is not i mean it's you're dependent
on a single platform which is amazon
that's known to compete very hostilely
and there's other other they could
change the algorithm and all of a sudden
your thing that was at the top is now at
the bottom um
there is definitely risk and so you got
to look at like okay
if my payback period is nine months i
feel pretty good about it if it's three
years i don't feel so good about it
anymore and so that's where you got to
like
you know place your bets
can i tell you about a really random
small one like that okay so our buddy uh
ramon tweeted this out he goes here's an
example of a silly stupid business so
ramon is ramon vanmir on twitter
and so he goes simple website moneymaker
this emoji website gets five million
visitors a month and all it does and i
use this by the way all the time because
if you're on your computer and you want
to use an emoji it's not easy to get the
keyboard up for the emoji thing so you
just
you you just google like laughing emoji
and then it gives it to you and it says
click to copy your to your clipboard and
then you go and you like
copy it you paste it on twitter or paste
it wherever you're writing your email or
whatever
and so um all it does is it lets you
look up you look up emoji copy paste
them and it'll also explain what the
emoji means
um
so there's like emojipedia is a good
example of this so emojipedia emojipedia
yeah i don't know if you've ever seen
this it's like the top-ranking um one
that comes through
uh when you search for this stuff
uh it's like wikipedia but for emoji and
so ramon was looking at you know like
depending on
and it's just plastered with ads there's
like ads everywhere on the site and it's
like depending on what the ad revenue is
like this site could be making between
50 and 150 000 a month of all profit
like do not underestimate these small
simple sites and we've talked about this
with crosswords uh sudoku games
things like that just like these really
simple things that people like to search
for and if you could own the domain you
could just have the really simple like
online game or like scrabble scrabble
word solver um you know crossword hint
get hint cheats you know whatever um
those little websites can be really good
so this emoji one i thought is another
example of that
and even better i was like oh who owns
this thing i was looking for the michael
gundlach some random engineer who's like
oh yeah i got a huge company that owns
so some company bought it they own it
and it's called zedge and i was like
okay what the heck is zedge
z-e-d-g-e and this is one of those
companies that you're like really
this so zedge is a public company
its market cap is around 130 million
dollars so it's a very small small cap
public company on the new york stock
exchange and what they do is they it's a
publisher or roll up they bought a bunch
of these
little apps and websites that just get a
bunch of traffic because people want
self-expression so they bought
wallpapers
ringtones
stickers
alarm clock sounds emoji emoji pdf like
things like that they bought all these
brought them all into one roof and then
they're a public company so you can go
see a bunch of their numbers so they'll
do like
you know
it's almost like 50 percent um they'll
do like 50 profit on their on their uh
on their product like at least operating
profit um and then you know like the
ebitda will be closer to like you know
two million or whatever on their uh
under each quarter why the hell would a
company like that go public don't go
public
uh yeah i think there's a bunch of
reasons why they might go public um but
i just thought it was interesting so
they have about 350 million people have
downloaded like their wallpaper app they
have they say they have 40 million
monthly active users
um and these companies that are just
hidden in plain sight so it's like um
you know let me just look at their
annual revenue again i don't know if i
have annual or quarterly i think that
they do about 20 million dollars a year
in revenue and 10 million 10 million
about operating profit
and um
yeah so they did 2017 they did um let's
see
pull this up
okay sales and revenue is a little lower
than what i saw here but i'm doing this
quick so basically for the last five
years it's just been flat like 10
million dollars of revenue two million
dollars of cogs you know their gross
income is between seven and eight
million and then then they pay for a
huge amount of you know like um
other sales and you know ssg a uh
expenses um and so you know they're
they're not showing a bunch of profit at
the end but i would bet that these
things are like spitting off profit if
you want uh you know they're putting
money in their own pockets basically
out of this so i thought that was just
like a really crazy little company
behind behind the stuff and it just
shows you how much money is in really
simple things that a lot of simple
things that a lot of people use so like
alarm clock sounds wallpapers that sort
of thing what um what's live reviews
uh this is an idea so so i just got a
sauna and i know you're in the market
for a song oh what time did you get
so i got a sanctuary a clear light
sanctuary uh like the infrared sauna
and
i like a lot of it like i like the size
the look the shape all that but it
doesn't
make me sweat enough and so i'm like
well that's the problem with infrared
that's the problem with infrared that's
the point of the sauna so i'm like well
that's a bust um
and i'm like so i'm like first i
realized okay i didn't have one of the
panels plugged in so that's why it was
like you know part of it was like dead
okay that was one issue it got better
and then it's like well the best way you
use it is you break a little sweat
before you go in so you just do like a
quick five minute ten minute cardio just
because what infrared's doing is it's
not warming up the air it's warming up
your body yeah just like microwaving you
it's microwaving you which seems like
pretty awful for you but i guess it's
not so bad i guess it's good for you
actually um you know blah blah blah heat
shock proteins blah blah blah so um
so i you know i broke a sweat before i
got in and it was better but i was like
dude i'm not trying to do all this i'm
trying to go sit the sun on sweat in
five minutes so i think for my house my
space like i didn't want to do extra
electrical i didn't want to like
do i didn't want to i didn't have a huge
space where i putting i put it in my
garage gym
so like
the dry sauna
in retrospect i would now hold that for
a dry sauna but uh it didn't really fit
my current situation so you know
whatever it is what it is so i was
thinking like god i i actually did the
research i i talked to people i read
reviews
but you know the thing that i feel like
is missing is i wish there was just
so like people have tried this qvc thing
where it's like oh i'm gonna go live and
i'm gonna sell this item and people have
tried to make qvc for mobile and it's
never really worked
and i don't know if this would work
either but i kind of wish this existed
just based on this current experience
and told me maybe there is a maybe there
is a product here which is
why can't why can't i go on and just say
i'd like to talk to somebody
about
saunas
and why isn't there a person live on
video who is a third party impartial
source
that can basically show me live on video
talk to me about what i'm looking for
dude this is exactly what mark laurie
said so mark laurie the guy who started
jet.com he sold it for three or two or
some billions of dollars to walmart he
said one thing that they were working on
at jet that could have been a massive
business but they shut it down for a
bunch of different reasons but he goes i
actually think it still could be big was
concierge shopping so you simply log on
and you just tell us you know i'm
looking for a toaster and a clerk is
online saying okay for your needs i
think this is best would you like this
one and he said that that would be a
big business
yeah and so like even with this actually
if you go to the website to buy this
thing you can't just buy the sauna
there's no buy button you had to call
someone but this is their sales rep
right so i called the sales rep it's 8
p.m she picks up she's an american
person i was like whoa what the heck
like i was like you worked this hour
like who are you like you were really
good at what your job like you know you
built a lot of trust quickly and you got
me over the line to buy the six thousand
dollar sauna um on the phone here and
and she was like yeah like where there's
a network the way we work is we only
sell the sonic company
yeah so it's owned by jacuzzi the the
the you know the jacuzzi company so
she's like yeah it's basically we have a
network of sales reps we all pick up the
phone uh you could if you're offline
you're offline you you didn't get that
commission she's like i get a commission
if you buy um and that's how we make our
money and she's like yeah like i make
good money like i'll sell i was like how
many of these you selling today she's
like on a good day i could sell like
four of these in a day and on a bad day
i'll sell like one or zero dude listen
the reason why you and i are pretty good
at what we do which in this case i'm
referring to just coming up with ideas
like people say [__] to us all the time
it's
and i get i'm kind of like
jerking ourselves off here sorry but
because of that question that you just
asked
and i do that all the time and people
are amazed that you could do that like
when you're just going to a food truck
you'd be like hey how many customers you
get a day and they just tell you and so
what you just did is a perfect example
you got intel that is hard to find but
it was very easy to get right and i
asked multiple i asked and you could
triangulate that's the the secret yeah
you don't ask a very rude question how
much money do you make or how much does
this company make i said
what's a good day you know how many do
you how many of these do you sell on a
good day so yeah already i softened the
blow by saying good day and i'm asking
just for a day that doesn't seem like
top secret information okay cool then i
say and then i was like i was like and
you're great at this like i i was like i
really like this like this was like kind
of an awesome experience for me on the
phone
i was like are you one of like the
better sales reps like do you like are
you like a
top performer or you like
uh like are you kind of like middle of
the pack she's like no i'm like actually
one of the top performers blah blah blah
and she's like you know i picked up the
phone at 8 pm a lot of people just don't
pick up the phone like i'm i work like i
work hard and i was like oh interesting
okay cool and then i was like i was like
how many reps are there
i'm just like and again i'm not like
digging i'm not like saying like and um
okay my next question is how many reps
are there i'm like i'm just sounding
amazed because i was amazed what you say
to that reply is wow are you guys all in
america
yeah yeah we're all in america wow which
i mean
were there like ten thousand of you of
course you know it's gonna be close oh
no it's way smaller hundreds oh like a
hundred ah more like 800 right right
exactly exactly and so i was able to
like suss out how this system works i
was like i was like well i was like
that's great so i was like i was like so
this is awesome so i bought this thing
and you're gonna make like what 400 or
500 bucks off this yes and she's like so
now i know the commission structure is
like you know i was able to kind of like
and i'm just doing it because i'm
curious i have no agenda i'm not
starting a sauna company i don't care
but i'm just trying to learn and then
like you know i took a piece of that to
our own i had a meeting with our own
team for e-commerce i was like hey you
know i had this kind of great experience
you know should we be having a phone
number on the site and like should we be
helping people like that like how would
that work we're a way lower price point
like would this still work
and um and then i met this guy uh ezra
ezra uh firestone is his name yeah he's
amazing he's super well known in the
e-commerce space and he's got this
famous brand called boom by cindy
joseph or something like that is that
makeup right it's like kind of like
makeup and like anti-staging
face cream stuff like that for like
women who are like 50 to 70 or something
that's what it looks like to me at least
and this brand does great i think he's
pretty open about it like he publishes
stuff like i think they do like 80 or
100 million dollars a year of revenue
and he told me that uh he told me on a
we i did a talk at ecom world he was
interviewing me and of course when was
that
uh like i don't know a couple weeks ago
oh that's pretty sick he's that's a
pretty legit thing yeah so he goes
he was like you know so how do you do
your sales like i don't know what do you
mean like this is shopify you push the
buy button he's like okay so you don't
do any live chat yeah we have chat but
like whatever customer service he goes
okay interesting he goes for us we do
phone you guys you don't need a phone i
go no we don't go do you does anybody do
phone does that [__] work
same thing same type of question that
will get somebody to like defend the
thing they do that [__] work that's what
you said i was like there's no way does
that [__] work and he was like dude 30
of our sales close over the phone
and i was like bing data point
interesting should i be doing that
that's like a learning
the next thing that you ask is yeah but
there's no way that's profitable and
they'll say yeah of course it's
profitable we only pay them eighteen
exactly eight dollars an hour
am i a bad entrepreneur no i'll tell you
that i'll tell you how it all breaks
down
so yeah that's exactly the how much do
they pay people questions how do they
pay people how much do they pay people
an hour
uh i don't know i didn't ask in this
case because we were live on the panel
but you know it had this been this
normal conversation i would have would
have been uh breaking it down
that's badass um all right you want to
do one more
wait
what's this fluffy stuff about luck of
timing let's do this do a non-fluffy one
because i feel like i've been doing a
lot of fluffy stuff lately i feel like
we've kind of been on a kick of like
sort of fluffy stuff because if you let
me i'm gonna talk about mindset all day
and the second thing is we did a lot of
like gossip about like you know like
billionaires and their like affairs and
[__] like that so i'm like okay just
noted i'm gonna like to turn that down a
little bit
so i want to do one more cool idea
because i think you know people love
that [__] okay so rebase um have you
seen this before before i put it on this
sheet
no i'm looking it up now all right so
you know the guy who's behind this that
guy levels um levels dot io
who is oh i love that guy kind of like
his name's peter levels i think is his
name uh his handle is levels.i o so he's
amazing prolific guy he was ahead of the
curve on like remote work so i remember
maybe six years ago
he was he created you know nomad list he
created a remote like a remote like uh
remote working slack was like oh if
you're a remote worker pay 10 bucks and
get into slack and hit like 6 000
members i was like whoa you made a lot
of money off this little like just a
slack invite i've never seen that and he
reveals all of his revenue so
i don't what's his so it's levels.io
that's his that's one of his sites he's
got like four sites i think and if you
go to levels and then scroll all okay so
he has his is his twitter name is levels
io i yeah it's probably pronounced
actually differently and you can see a
link to all of his websites and looks
like he's got close to 10 there and if
you click them and then
see the little meter in his location
oh well that's amazing for one amazing
that's a feeling
oh my god that's beautiful so good so
on twitter where you put your location
and most people just write like san
francisco or new york
instead he just he used the emoji for to
create like 10 squares and it's like a
meter
and
it go and at the end of the meter it
says five million dollars a year and
then he shows the meter is like
like 60 of the way there um which shows
that he's kind of like you know he's
probably at two and a half uh to three
million dollars a year is what he's
making it's just a subtle
it's a subtle thing
very nicely done very interesting very
cool i like it and if you go to any of
his sites so it looks like he's got
eight or something sites listed and you
click around you're gonna see a phrase
on all of his sites called open startup
and i just sent you a link do you see
the link i sent you and you could see
all of his metrics so you can see how
much revenue they have how much like
he's got weird metrics how much co2
removed from the atmosphere github
commits daily revenue daily signups
meetups organized new paid membership
uh live streaming events
um last month sign ups how many
customers are in total how many page
views where the pages are coming from
you can see everything the uh the uptime
of the websites this guy's amazing and
if you know just nomad list is doing 531
000 a year it's halfway to the goal of a
million dollars a year from this
business and this guy
we just explained how he's kind of got
this like unique little easter egg on
his twitter he's got like little things
like that throughout all of his websites
and so this guy is in my mind he this
man's an artist he's this guy's like
he's an artist who just so happens to uh
his art just so happens to make money
this guy's i love this guy i don't know
his name peter peter i think he said
peter levels that's his full name i
didn't know that i always just thought
his company was called levels so if you
look at like one of his um things i was
going to show you so okay so his latest
thing this thing called rebase
and he tries to like sniff out a trend
and then quickly spin up the semi-viral
slightly profitable like a semi-viral
simple profitable version of a website
so
uh what is rebase rebase is people are
trying to relocate with the pandemic and
with tax changes and with cryptocurrency
and all this good stuff people are
more like kind of uh you know like fluid
than ever there are people are gender
fluid and they're location fluid there's
a fluidity
going on so he basically said
uh portugal came out and portugal said
we wanna they i think in 2021 they had
the largest population
uh decrease in the last 50 years and so
they decided all right our population's
shrinking we need foreigners to come
live here and spend here and work here
so they said the portuguese government
said we want to attract high-tech remote
workers and they gave out they create a
program called the nhr program
and so the nhr program basically has a
bunch of benefits now i don't know if
they're all as good as advertised
meaning like i didn't go read the fine
print but here's some of the things it
says
zero percent tax on foreign income so
they're not going to tax you for income
that comes outside of the state um zero
percent tax on crypto
it's considered a currency unlike in the
u.s where it's considered a property
uh zero percent tax on dividends zero
percent tax on wealth 10 tax on pension
20 tax on freelancing so that's like you
know where what a lot of people would do
there there's no minimum stay you can
get fast track for eu passport um
you know they have a whole bunch of like
you know sort of things that are uh
benefits for coming here you know we're
we have a 90 vaccination rate we have
friendly people blah blah so that's so
he created a website that just has the
sales benefit the benefits of if you
wanted to relocate or get a passport in
portugal
and then what levels did was you
basically created uh
okay here's the on-ramp to portugal so
it's like
for 150 bucks you'll do an on-boarding
call and we'll walk you through it and
it'll be a tax
expert and a lawyer that will analyze
your situation
for 650 we'll get you set up with
portuguese residency and you'll get a
portuguese tax id for 150
150 bucks a year we'll do your taxes and
it's like start now here's the button
and i was like this is such a smart
simple um you know simple idea
and already it's like booked out so you
know he his max was that he could do
that the lawyer could do 50 50 calls per
month and immediately it was at 300
calls per month and so he's like trying
to hire another lawyer so he can scale
it up a little bit more
if you had to ask like someone asked me
the other day like who i admire and i
would ask it a little bit differently
which is who am i jealous of this guy
peter i'm looking at his websites i am
jealous of
i'm jealous of so many things about him
the first is creativity it just oozes
and second
he can do it like every like everything
that i see on his website i'm like oh my
god this is perfect this is the perfect
example of how a product should be made
uh he's this guy is
incredibly prolific and incredibly he's
like a music producer to me like he's a
producer of websites he's just making
these little hit songs uh and they're
not like
he's not trying to be justin bieber like
the one mega hit franchise uh that goes
on tour he's just a producer that makes
dope beats and instead of beats he just
makes dope websites and it's like
pay for a dope lifestyle
yeah i mean
subscription revenue he's got like look
at inflationchart.com that's one of his
yeah this website tracks real inflation
which is happening the governments don't
tell you about in their official numbers
okay super easy i understand that's just
a really cute neat widget again
even on um on what's it called the
website i was just talking about on
rebase the very first benefit it goes
mcdonald's has the royale deluxe
mcdonald's in portugal has the royal
deluxe and the big tasty double that was
the first benefit right because he could
have just gone into like tax benefit tax
benefit but he
let me get you let me break you know let
me let me break the ice here
a little fun little easter egg a little
fun little nugget that just shows you
who this site's built by it's built by
somebody who's got a personality it's
built by an indie software maker not
some stiff company or bureaucracy and i
think these little touches matter that's
why he's an artist this guy's amazing i
love this guy good good good fine um
i've known about him for a little while
i i always thought he was really
talented i didn't realize that he was
like
the kanye of like
internet website builders
uh yeah he's great um okay so i wouldn't
even say he's like you know rick rubin
or something like that he's got he's got
his own stick um
anything else we want to do otherwise we
could wrap it no no we could wrap it we
could save that other i i want to hear
about some of these things that you have
on here but we can save them okay sounds
good we're out
[Music]
you